so how to be successful if SEO the first
thing that we need to remember is first
of all not to overdo it and not to
underestimate it back in the day you
could make a lot of money with SEO just
by exchanging links and optimizing for
specific keywords on your website that
was amazing that was the gold rush of
SEO but that's not happening anymore a
lot of websites are getting slapped and
a lot of people who made a lot of money
are not making that money anymore and
they don't have a choice because what
what was walking back then is not
working anymore and the best thing that
you should remember about SEO is that
it's about the relevancy of your
offering to the audience and when people
are using search engines they are
basically asking questions so if we'll
think about it if you're typing into the
search engine chip close New York you're
basically asking a question right where
can I find cheap closing in New York or
what kind of cheap closing can I find in
New York and so on and so forth so you
want your website to be ranked in the
top so you want to create some kind of
answers to those questions so if we're
thinking also about what kind of content
to create so we need to entertain all we
need to educate we need also to answer
questions one of the most important
things is how to know which keyword we
should invest on there's so many
keywords people are arriving to our site
using 50,000 different kinds of keywords
some of them are even titles some of
them are branded with using our name
some of them are not how can we know
what to use so there's a lot of ways
similar web is one of them that you can
search for the keywords that are leading
users to your competitors the keywords
that are leading users to the websites
or mobile apps that you think that are
similar to yours and you can start and
finding those keywords creating creating
the list and then you know what kind of
content to create and what kind of
answers what kind of questions you want
to answer
you want really to avoid nasty tricks
blackhat SEO this can be very gratifying
in the beginning you can get a lot of
users but you'll eventually get slapped
it happened in the past it will happen
it will happen in the future